how do you factor in like the economy
one is what's the marketplace we're
going after so the marketplace that
we're going after is e-learning which as
a category is is set to two and a half x
over the next five years now compared to
like any anything else that's great
growth so from uh like the win behind
the sales perspective we've got that
number two is that in a you know bad
economy future especially an
inflationary environment businesses that
have low capital expenses and high cash
flow tend to be businesses that fare
better because there's easier pricing
power and because you don't have to put
capital back into the business to expand
it those businesses are more flexible
and so the types of businesses that we
work with are by nature low capital
expense businesses high cash flow and so
for those reasons we feel really well
equipped for an inflationary period that
might come in the future if you're
enjoying these tips and tricks and you
want more in-depth content go to the
youtube video and check out all the good
stuff that we have there